Understanding how birds navigate has fascinated
scientists for generations.
And we’ve finally cracked that old egg…
turns out, they have quantum compasses in
their eyes.
Easy peasy.
Half of all bird species migrate to find food
as the seasons turn cold.
The exact pathway and location changes between
species, but they all follow a more-or-less
north-south pattern.
Incredibly, even for those that hunt on land,
birds will take the most direct route, even
flying over big bodies of water to conserve
energy.
But how do these birds know where to go?!
They don’t know to follow roads or turn
at that one landmark -- also you’re a bird
do you even know what a landmark is?!
You don’t.
But birds do have one advantage, a built-in
compass.
New evidence from two separate studies — one
looking at zebra finches and the other European
robins — found some migrating birds have
proteins in their eyes that give them a sort
of “sixth sense” allowing them to detect
the Earth’s magnetic field.
In both species, the researchers studied the
proteins Cry1, Cry2 and Cry4, three proteins
called cryptochromes that are associated with
their bodies’ internal circadian clock.
They found that Cry1 and Cry2 levels rise
and fall in regular cycles during the day,
but the level of Cry4 is constant.
The simplest explanation is that birds need
to produce this protein all the time, for
some reason.
So they looked more closely at Cry4.
This protein is a peculiar one.
Clustered in a part of the birds’ retina
that is especially sensitive to blue light,
this protein is made of a kind of molecule
that sometimes has an odd number of electrons.
The scientists theorize, that as incoming
light enters the eye, a photon hits the cryptochrome
protein, exciting the electrons on it.
That energy is transferred between two molecules
within the protein yielding two free electrons
that are quantum entangled and therefore,
correlated.
They theorize the electrons’ spin forms
a coherent quantum state that reacts to a
weak external magnetic field, say, for example,
the Earth’s magnetic field.
Basically, these two electrons are reacting
to the bird flying through the Earth’s magnetic
field.
As the bird turns or moves, the electrons
spin differently causing different messages
to be sent to the birds brain.
The chemical signals that are sent to the
bird’s brain, allow it to detect the magnetic
field to within just 5 degrees.
Again, theoretically, of course.
The Cry4 protein essentially acts like a magnetic
compass; and enough blue light hits the retina
to trigger the electrons’ spin to release
that chemical any time of day.
Which is insane if you think about it.
When we humans study quantum particles it
requires supercooling atoms in a lab environment,
and huge complex machinery.
The inside of a bird’s eye is warm, wet
and chaotic.
How the heck does this work?
We don’t really know.
We also don’t know how the chemical signal
part of the compass sends messages to the
brain, or how the birds perceive the magnetic
field.
We’d need a literal bird’s eye view to
fill in these final pieces of the puzzle.
Climate change is ALSO a puzzle, which is
why you should watch Hot Mess!
THIS episode looks at how long we’ve known
about climate change -- longer than you think.
If you care about our planet, if you care
about climate change and you want to learn
more about it: absolutely watch Hot Mess.
It’s a great show from PBS Digital Studios
(Who we love) and I think you’ll love it.
Thanks a lot for watching Seeker. We'll see you next time.